[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans la première d'
interdit d'interdire une émission
culturelle que vous retrouverez chaque
jour désormais du lundi au jeudi entre
19h et 20h
et pour commencer un débat un vrai car
c'est ce qui manque le plus à la
télévision il ya des réformes en cours
qui elle continue toujours d'aller dans
le même sens
mais l'alternance depuis 20 ans vous
savez la bête pour selon moi serait pas
d alternance pour moi c'est pas de
l'avenir tandis qu'elle s'est maquillée
non moi je trouve ça ce qui se passe je
pense à radical d'avoir aujourd'hui des
gens qui décèdent dans des couloirs
d'urgence est élevé des gab x fi 2
balles les trois à trente mètres des
services est comme ça que les gens quoi
parce que mais monsieur là on ne peut
être dangereuse mais c'est surtout la
personne qui l'utilisé le surgé aux
différents ratios ça serait complètement
stupide
il est même pas capable de savoir ont
tiré quand il fait ça à des gamins la
question se gérer c'est d'être capable
de promouvoir un autre modèle
d'agriculture
voilà un autre modèle habitudes
culinaires mais il n'y a jamais eu de
secret mais sa très bonne opposition
mais la plupart des gens aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont hostiles aux guildes a
aujourd'hui ne le sont pas parce qu'il
veut changer de modèle agricole la
question de la police la question de la
monnaie
la question de l'armée la question de la
sécurité ce sont des questions clés
gilet jaune aurait dû pouvoir poser sans
que les vieux routards de les vieux
briscards de la politique vise mais on a
les réponses vous inquiétez pas on les a
répondu c'est chomsky qui disait que la
propagande la propagande et à la
démocratie ce cas la matraque est dans
un état très bien mais je peux déjà vous
découvert chomsky avec qui j'ai cosigné
des tribunes en chine il sera en tôle et
dirait le dixième de ce qu'il dit il
serait temps 0 1 sans john des lois
changent les gens vont rejoindre cette
date du 5 décembre porteurs de colère
extrêmement variées et qui déborde de
beaux des colères qui porte sur poids
alors moi je dirais des colères qui
porte sur un monde il faut pas oublier
que trogne pas a été élu comme barack
obama avant lui sur une plate forme anti
guerre l'élection d'obama elle est
essentiellement due à la guerre en irak
en fait la guerre en afghanistan par
extension merci d'avoir accepté mon
invitation vous essuyer les plâtres
thorens et bien oui j'ai été chez
d'huile vous remercie de m'avoir invité
parce que vous m'avez proposé de
débattre de sujets qu'il ne m'a été
impossible jusque là de mettre sur la
chaîne publique
la mère l'espace et l'espace numérique
en tant que nouveaux territoires et
nouvelles frontières bien venu non pas
sur le plateau de date à date arrière
mais chez moi je suis confiné comme vous
tous nous allons passer toute cette
émission avec le philosophe edgar morin
qui lui aussi continuer chez lui
les gars morin qui publie trois livres
pour la première fois on a l'impression
que la population blanche
une majorité d'américains donc les
blancs s'indigne à son tour soutient les
manifestants et puis ça sort ça ça
embrasse le monde entier et puis la
france notamment
[Musique]